[Music]
[Applause]
there's a lot of people
rick sudcliffe who calls the cubs games
used to be with espn a long time and uh
former
pitcher uh cy young winner and rick
sutcliffe joining us on the program sud
how are you this morning
well dan i got to be honest um after the
big
golf tournament went over the weekend um
my legal name has been changed to rick
putcliff oh
okay congratulations uh who did you take
down in the
golf event here putt cliff well it was a
couple's event
and um you've seen my swing you've seen
my game it
you know obviously it's all about my
partner and uh
my wife carried us and uh the two songs
that i picked for our wedding that
carried her down the aisle
um were both by elvis um the hawaiian
wedding song
and can't help falling in love with you
did you cry
well i was worried she wasn't going to
say i do when she heard the songs that i
[Laughter]
did you cry when she walked down the
aisle did you cry during the ceremony
uh no i cried you know what i was
i was bawling like a baby when our
daughter got married and i i know you
can relate to that
yeah um yeah no i was i i think i was
pretty hungover uh
during the ceremony as as i was
yesterday when uh
i wasn't able to join you guys oh that's
why you didn't join us yeah because i
said
i said to fritzy i said uh reach out to
sudcliff see if he wants to join us i
didn't know which days you
you were drinking in which way days you
weren't so that's that's our mistake
there
um yeah it's a monday tuesday wednesday
or
no alcohol because uh we we play the
role of grandpa
the first three days of the week all
right the seven inning
complete game but not no hitter by
madison baumgartner
um is this good for baseball
that they're not going to recognize it
should they recognize it as a no-hitter
yes um i i i think it was terrific for
baseball last year with
everything that was going on just trying
to get the games in
uh trying not to hurt people
particularly extending the starters and
overusing the bullpen
um and as long as they kept it the same
this year
they know it has to be and and if if
they take that away from him
i mean if they give him a no hitter
who's that you think nolan ryan is going
to get mad
no i mean the only guy that's gonna hurt
is him
and the fans that were there that had
the opportunity to experience it and
dan you know how i feel um you know i
think the record book is
in my opinion kind of a joke anyway um
the record
for all-time home runs is 7.55 the
single season record is 61.
there's a lot of things in there that
shouldn't be there i i just don't think
this no hitter is one that should be
taken away
yeah i just wondered about that because
it's it's one thing for us to say
because we didn't play the game at that
high of a level but i don't know if
bumgarner cares
i mean knowing him he probably doesn't
care first of all rick he doesn't
we know that yeah so when it comes to
hey it's a no-hitter you can't call it a
complete game
but you can't call it a no-hitter like
is it a complete game
what is a complete game what's a seven
in and complete game well then it's a
seven inning no hitter that's a complete
game so i know we get caught up in
semantics there but
you know the new baseball rules at least
baseball is staying
in the conversation the nfl always stays
in the conversation because of new rule
changes
and i think with baseball i don't know
if it's progress
but it is dialogue and i think that
that's important for people
to talk about baseball and you know it's
your livelihood
but you know you're competing it's it's
tough sledding with uh
trying to compete with football the nba
playoffs coming up
and you know baseball sort of you know
hangs there in the on deck circle
you're exactly right dan i mean you're
you're looking to add that excitement
and now you're saying by rule you're
going to take it away
um the funny part about it as you were
saying that i was thinking
you know it barely qualifies for a
quality start
yeah you just got one inning more than
what that is and
a couple of years ago um we were in la
uh luchambi and i and we were blessed um
jackie robin rachel robinson threw out
the first pitch
sandy koufax escorted her and when they
came in
um sandy i had known since i was an 18
year old kid
uh back in vero beach he was kind enough
to come in and sit down with us
and dan i i asked you were talking
clayton kershaw was on the mound and
about the comparison and everything but
i asked him about a quality start
with six innings and and three earned
runs or less and he goes rick i always
thought a quality start was at the end
of the game
when i shook the catcher's hand
which he did quite a few times he
certainly did yeah but to your point
that's exactly how a lot of things have
changed and i just think we all need to
evolve with it
i then i go back to i think it's been so
long the old six world series the one
between
i had to be 08 philadelphia and tampa
bay
and if you remember uh the phillies were
about to win
it was hailing it was cold they needed
to call it a game and they didn't want
to because the phillies
had a one-run lead and they were going
to be crowned champions because the game
had gone five innings
i'm doing the game with gary thorne on
mlb international
we get word from major league baseball
they changed the rule during the game
they said
we're not we're not gonna let it in this
way we're gonna pick it up from here and
continue so
you know these rules are constantly
changing and let bum have his no hitter
and
to your point he doesn't care anyway
we're talking to rick sudcliff
cubs marquee sports network analyst it
feels like
the rivalry has shift to the west coast
with dodgers padres that's the new the
red sox and yankees
uh you got the dodgers playing well you
got shohei ohtani with
the angels playing well mike trout baton
426
giants tied for first place with the
dodgers feels like baseball
is alive and well on the west coast well
as you know dan i've been here in san
diego
since spring training got shut down in
the middle of march last year
uh getting on the first plane this
weekend to fly back to chicago to do
some games from wrigley field
uh feeling the excitement um here with
the san diego padres
uh fernando tatias junior a guy you just
can't take your eye off of
people talk about manny machado helping
tatis i think it's the other way around
i think that machado knows tatis is
watching everything he does and because
of that
he's even taken his game to another
level
um it's exciting um you know it's just
that
i i'm so glad more than anything i did
on espn radio
i did the division series between the
cardinals and the padres
it was here they played it at petco the
padres came back to win game two in game
three
the excitement in the city was amazing
but if that ballpark could have been
packed the the the the
the excitement that tatis jr brings to a
game and what's going on
with this team that's the exciting part
you know with all the good things going
on right now we
the game's just not the same without
fans and hopefully
slowly but surely we're gonna we're
gonna get them all back okay
now i know that there's old school and
you know in your era and when you
pitched if tatis
did what he did to trevor bauer
and he did that to you how would you
have reacted
i'll give you a story at 1983 or 4
reggie jackson takes me deep
and he does something like that and i
mean i literally
looked at him all the way around the the
you know the diamond as he strolled and
as i came in
bert blylan comes up and he goes what's
wrong and i go i'm gonna kill him
i go i'm gonna kill him i'm gonna hit
him right in the mouth
anyway he let me go an inning because
reggie wasn't coming up
and then burke came to me in the dugout
and he goes let me tell you something
he's gotten me four or five times he's
hit over 500 home runs
he's earned the right to do whatever he
want
and you know i'm gonna tell you and it's
really your fault
because you're the reason i feel like
that espn hired me
um you remember opening day i'm sitting
in the bleachers
sandberg came back and you started
sportscenter with
two former cubs returned to wrigley you
showed sandberg getting a base hit
and you showed me in the bullpen with a
beer
this big chugging it down
and because you said it espn go well
let's bring him in and then
then you told the story about grandpa's
tie which i will
for the rest of my life trying to repay
you for being able to mention that
but i i just um i forgot your question
now
but would you would you throw are you
you're not drinking right now right
i'm not i got a little coffee cup oh
okay i just want to make sure
um if if if tatis did that to you
you would probably pop him but but
bowers said hey look i get it man i i
celebrate he celebrates it it feels like
you need a whole younger generation to
embrace this
not worried about old school remember
when when ken griffey jr
had his hat on backwards and people
the old school cool they were like they
were like
turn your hat around you know i know
right like
we've come a long way since that but i
just wonder
if that kind of celebration can continue
will pitchers
allow that to happen well then to your
point and
and to to go back to me saying it was
your fault
it all started with espn and i had to
adjust
because of what sportscenter was doing
when we when you would start
sportscenter you would start off with
somebody hitting a home run
and doing we're hoping to see tattoos
and major league baseball has to be
hoping for that to to bring the young
kids to get more
i've got my eight-year-old grandson
playing baseball now they're having a
ball
we need more and more of that but i
really think
all of those theatrics and everything
that goes on with a home run now
the sports center started all of that
and baseball needs the attention because
we know what's going on with
with with kids and basketball and
football we've got to bring a lot more
of that our way
in any way that we can what would you do
with shohei ohtani
i i think for him to be elite it it
comes down to him being on the mountain
i think that it's more important for him
to be a number one or number two
to the angels than it is for him to to
hitting that lineup
um this is a special thing and
and i i'll be honest with you up until
this first month of the season
i i thought he was just okay as a hitter
i thought what made him elite was was as
a pitcher
it's it's not that way this guy can fly
around the bases i mean he's just a
he's a super talent that i i just think
you have to take care of him
as a pitcher first and when you can use
this bat in the lineup or pinch it with
him or whatever that's fine but
um i i just think it's special what he
does out there on the mount
and that more than anything to me is
what the angels need
yeah i just wonder that is it's going to
be
sort of half in and half out it's like
bo jackson when bo
played baseball and football and you
wondered if he committed to one
you know would he have been a hall of
famer and i wonder that with otani
if you just said look just concentrate
on pitching
and you know or just concentrate on
hitting
i just wonder try to do both if he's
going to be able to do that and we'll
and will reach his full potential i
think he's got the perfect guy
making those decisions in joe madden um
joe's such a great communicator i know
you've had him on the show
you learned something every single time
you're around him and i'm sure that that
that conversation
with with ohtani it goes on daily you
know where you at how you feeling
um everything is penciled in other than
every fifth day
uh on what his schedule is going to be
it's great to talk to you son
uh safe travels there and uh have fun
you got
cubs and the dodgers coming up in in uh
may right we do next week yeah please
come see us at wrigley this year if you
can
um can you give me good seats you know
what hey and i i can get you great seats
and you know gracie's gonna be there i'm
working with him
i got a question for you okay you know
that gracie hit or
you know that um you know that david
ross
hit his last home run in game seven of
the world series right yeah
all right without going to todd or
somebody on your computer
tell me who david ross hit his first
home run off the
they're in your ear right now i know you
didn't no no nobody
nobody don't help him don't help him
who uh gave up his first home run a
left-hander for the arizona diamondbacks
not randy johnson okay
uh madison bumgarner
mark grace
so he came in agency pitcher
david ross did his first hold on oh my
gosh off of mark graves
we were there doing the game and just
real quick nano gracie looked to me in
the booth and he goes what do i do
i called the pitches for the first two
guys i knew him the third guy came up
david ross i'd never heard of him i look
to gracie and i go
curveball and he voices to me on espn he
goes
i don't have one
wait see you're in the booth and
gracie's on the mound
i'm in the booth hey you know i can
embellish but this is one thousand
percent the truth here buddy ow
i miss you pal hey great to see you son
and uh
thanks for joining us anytime that's
rick sutcliffe
he uh does the cubs games for marquis
sports network
and he's got next up will be dodgers at
the cup